The program must have more than one bug. Let's find out what's wrong with the
syllable calculation. Before we go too far, let's make sure that text is
actually hello. I'll place the break point in the beginning of syllable
calculation. I can't place it right here because the declaration of the method
isn't really a line that you can run. Now, I'll run the program. It still
thinks it's running, so I'll just hit terminate and now I'll run it. Or keep
trying that same sentence, and it stopped and it looks like the text is right
this time, it's hello. That's good. So, I'll keep stepping. Probably the most
interesting part is when count gets incremented. So, let's try stepping it till
that happens. Stepping, stepping, keep going, all right, we're getting closer,
we're now inside this four, inside the if. We'll step to the next one. Alright,
and now I'm at count. What is the value of letter right now? If you step until
count is incremented, right here, what is the value of letter?